on
n'imaginait pas qu'on puisse tuer des
hommes comme ça
et je parle pas des femmes des enfants
[Musique]
à deux heures de l'après-midi les ss
revenus
à l'époque on ne connaissait rien il
décale concentration dit les
arrestations pour d'où les allemands ne
dépassez jamais passé
dans le village où peut-être voir les
rues par mois ils se sont arrêtés en dur
c'est à dire hier deux véhicules se lier
sur ses véhicules il y avait dans chaque
véhicule une dizaine de soldats et
lorsque je les ai vu s'arrêter à eau du
village que j'ai vu des salles du
village et courir
de chaque côté
j'ai pas réalisé moi je quitte moment là
je vais voir ma petite soeur qui qui est
à l'école
b qui est sûr le schale fois avec sa
maîtresse qui pleure parce qu'elle a
peur et je vais la voir à le désarmer
très inquiète pas on va rentrer à la
maison
c'est parce qu'elle veut te faire de mal
et je lui disais ça
sincèrement
parce que je craignais rien du tout et
un soldat qui s'est adressé à nous en
france et qui nous a dit
ceux qui ont des armes
voulait déclare vous fait connaître il
me l'a dit dans le village il ya des
armes de guerre il a bien précisé il ya
des armes de guerre nous allons les
rechercher et ceux qui ne sont pas
concernés sont relâchés moi je serai
chez moi qui avait pas d'armes de guerre
et il y en aurait pas aux radios le plus
c'est un prétexte pour
paulo
rassuré les soldats sont passés au
milieu du groupe
et ont fait mettre les femmes les
enfants du côté la droite se cantonne à
la haye les hommes on nous a fait mettre
sur le soir de gauche les femmes et les
enfants on les a rassemblés dans
l'église et on les y à mitrailler et
brûlé dit
les hommes
on les a emmenés dans des granges et
abattu nous les a noté 4/5
amaral et il y avait du fun la rage
avait de la paille et tout et on s'est
assis au fond de la gorge
la paille un moment donné il ya un
soldat je pense que c'était le chef qui
a fait le tour de notre groupe et qui
nous a fait signe comme ça de nous lever
il nous a rien eu a fait signe de me
lever
et le temps qu'ils reviennent à l'entrée
de la grange et à une forte détonation
dans le virage
est là c'est le final de
l'exécution des hommes c'est la
fusillade je me trouve sur les autres
ou les bourgs ans où les morts
c'est quand même
un moment difficile après ils nous ont
couvert de foin de tout ce qui peut
brûler et
ils ont mis le feu sur nous et là je
calcule jeudi
robert
je savais que j'allais mourir
parce que je savais je parle c'est que
les soldats étaient devant la porte
c'est l'hiver les sentiers et on me tuer
mais je préfère mourir
d'une balle que de que le péri brûlés
vifs
et une chance ils sont pas là ils sont
partis
[Musique]
ce moment là je suis seul je veux
personnes vont partir et puis après
c'est
cette évasion comme on peut et puis je
suis arrivé dans un mot il était presque
nuit j'ai bien vu une une fenêtre à
allumer pas de bruit que les chiens qui
aboyaient
je veux jeudi ils ont peut-être tu aussi
je frappe à sa porte parce que j'avais
aussi par des soldats de la lui que les
soldats la personne qui m'a ouvert
libre vers m'a dit mais qu'est ce que tu
feras la ceta alors je lui dis entre
tous les hommes ici tout est mal une
ville incendiés fusillé
torturé un désert et penser au
cataclysme
m
robert hebras le 10 juin 1944 vous étiez
dans cette grange oui mais j'ai été dans
cette grange comment vous avez de vous
échapper
c'est la destinée qui m'avait échappé
c'est tout
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il ya un message c'est que
on revit
les bras sacre en revue les massacres
moi ça me touche beaucoup
malheureusement j'ai peur que
nos petits-enfants
arrière-petits-enfants
et des soucis avec
les prochaines heures parce que d'autres
guerres
[Musique]